I mentioned last week that liberals were
reinstating mask mandates in Hollywood
and on campus I suggested this was a
test run two and a half years after the
covid lockdowns coordinated right on
time to justify more BS ahead of the
2024 election
and I'm sorry to say
Joe Biden is already proving me right
with his latest announcement pushing for
a new round of vaccines
speaking with the Associated Press Joe
Biden said quote
I signed off this why don't do a good
buying impression
he said quote I signed off this morning
on a proposal we have to present to the
Congress a request for additional
funding for a new vaccine that is
necessary that works
a new vaccine is necessary not to stop
infection or transmission of covid which
it has never successfully done but to
set the stage to rig the election again
the same way the Liberals did in 2020.
unless there be any confusion Joe Biden
added quote it will likely be
recommended that everybody get the
vaccine no matter whether they've gotten
it before or not
it might seem surprising that Biden
would push the exact same old talking
points years after they were all
thoroughly debunked including by some of
his own experts and officials
but it should not surprise anyone
because the scheme worked perfectly last
time
the libs got their lockdowns
they got the power they wanted they
changed all the election laws and no one
managed to stop them with a record of
success like that why would the
Democrats even consider changing their
strategy now I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show we've got
president Trump's statement on the most
lucrative mug shot in the history of
photography or criminal justice we'll
get to that in a second first though
amid the historic Crackdown on
conservatives
the Liberal Republicans are trying to
shift the focus back to what really
matters and that of course is funding
the war in Ukraine Senator Romney take
it away
single most important thing we can do to
strengthen ourselves relative to China
is to you is to see Russia defeated in
Ukraine because their allies and and
Russia being weakened weakens their Ally
China I mean so uh and by the way being
able to to take an amount which equals
what about five percent of our military
budget but actually less than five
percent of our military budget each year
to help the ukrainians is about about
the best national defense spending I
think we've ever done we're losing no
lives in Ukraine and the ukrainians are
fighting heroically against Russia
that has 1500 nuclear weapons aimed at
us it's like so we are we're
diminishing and devastating the Russian
military uh for a very small amount of
money related to what we spend in the
rest of Defense a weakened Russia is a
good thing it tells it tells China to
rethink their territorial ambition uh it
tells Russia perhaps most importantly
that the the Putin vision
of uh of re-establishing the the Russian
Empire and and grabbing the old former
Soviet republics that that's not
something that's going to work
this is the best argument for funding
the war in Ukraine I think that the
Liberals can make
and it's an argument that sounds
somewhat convincing even until you ask
yourself
how is Russia going to be defeated in
Ukraine
the whole argument rests on this premise
that Russia can be defeated in Ukraine
how does Russia get defeated in Ukraine
does anybody seriously believe that the
Ukraine military Valiant though it may
be is going to repel the Russians and
totally Vanquish them from the country
no nobody seriously believes that
so what has been going on for the last
year year and a half is what a lot of
people predicted which is just a lot of
Bloodshed a lot of death but without
really moving the calculus of the war
but there is no evidence that Russia is
going to be repelled from the eastern
part of Ukraine from Crimea anything
like that
the way to defeat Russia in Ukraine
would be to drastically escalate the war
the United States is already practically
speaking a belligerent in the war and
Russia has said as much we're the only
reason our funding our arms our
equipment it's the only reason that
Ukraine is able to put up anything like
a fight right now
so the only way to totally defeat Russia
in Ukraine would be to severely escalate
that war which would be
to launch World War III that would be a
direct con something we avoided for the
entirety of the Cold War it would launch
a direct conflict between the United
States and a nuclear former superpower
in Russia do you do you really think
that would make America safer
no
but but these Geniuses in Washington
the the the liberal establishment
Egghead wonk people they don't seem to
get that the war in Ukraine to me is a
perfect example of the IQ bell curve
meme where you've got the drooling idiot
at the bottom he says duh why we
spending money in Ukraine Ukraine
doesn't matter the right is drooling on
himself and then you get to that really
smart guy the Mitt Romney there in the
middle he says well actually this is the
best way to pursue America's interest
this is the most important thing we
could possibly be doing because if
you've figured out 25 of defense and
then you get up to the genius Jedi
voodoo magic guy up at the top and he
says actually the war in Ukraine is
extremely dumb and we should wrap it up
there and he agrees with the guy he was
drooling
as is so often the case
they
one could easily convince oneself that
continuing to fund this endless war in
Ukraine would help America's interest in
that more Russians die
and it's kind of a dark argument but I
at least see how Romney gets to that
argument but where does it end these
people these guys running the liberal
status quo they never have any clear
articulation of what happens at the end
of all this what happens at the end of
mass migration what happens at the end
of the sexual Revolution what happens at
the end of this foreign policy of
constant War what's the what's the point
of it all the point of it all is the
diminishment of our civilization or just
no end at all now when the political
order is pretty wonky as it is you're
probably going to want to protect your
assets you'll want to check out Birch
gold right now text Knowles to 98 98 98
as central banks and countries like
China India and Australia begin
transitioning to a digital currency the
Federal Reserve has been contemplating
the same for the U.S with the digital
currency the government could track
every single purchase you make officials
could even prohibit you from purchasing
certain products and easily freeze or
Seize Your Money these are some of the
reasons that concerned Americans reach
out to Birch gold they want to have a
physical asset like gold that is
independent of the US dollar you can
protect your IRA or 401K by diversifying
with gold from Birch gold historically
gold has been a safe haven in times of
high uncertainty which is right now
learn if gold is right for you
text Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98.98
they will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
upon text Knowles Canada wlas 298-98 98
speaking of
Liberal Republicans a prominent liberal
Republican who happens to be running for
president in 2024
is insistent that the Joe Biden Hunter
Biden corruption investigation is not
going to make one little bit of a
difference come November well look uh
Hunter Biden's not on the ballot and I
you you know that I predicted weeks
before the hunter Biden plea was
rejected that it would be rejected
because it was a completely one-sided
plea deal in favor of Hunter Biden now
he's going to face the same type of
trial that Donald Trump's going to face
and and here's the interesting part you
know some of those voters who say that
say the hunter Biden the thing matters
but Donald Trump's doesn't
um that's just wishful thinking the fact
is that the two people who would be on
the ballot if we nominated Donald Trump
will be Donald Trump and Joe Biden not
Hunter Biden and the fact is it's the
conduct of the people who are running
for office it's going to matter the most
we may find out more about President
Biden in the months to come
there it is you see he hints at the
complete undercutting of his argument
right there at the end because what he
says is look this is this match is going
to be about Trump and Biden if Trump is
the nominee it's going to be Trump
versus Biden and no one's going to care
about Hunter Biden because Hunter
Biden's not on the ballot
sure but the probe into Hunter Biden is
also not about Hunter Biden
that's why we're not really all that
concerned about his sex crimes that's
why we're really not all that concerned
about his drug crimes
they're good tabloid material but that's
not really what Republicans are focused
on
we're focused on the political
corruption we're focused on the payments
from Ukraine we're focused on the
payments from China we're focused on
payments from other powers around the
world that we're paying Hunter Biden
because Hunter was selling his father's
influence as the vice president
we're interested in that Hunter Biden
corruption because it implicates Joe we
don't even need to guess at this we've
got we've got the whole hard drive full
of text messages and emails connecting
Joe to these crimes we've got a
handwritten letter from Joe Biden to
Hunter Biden's business partner Devin
Archer a handwritten letter that proves
that Joe Biden invited Devin Archer to a
meeting with Xi Jinping the president of
China or it may have been the previous
president of China at the time because
this this goes back now like a decade
the we've got evidence after evidence
after evidence and now we've got Victor
shoken who is the prosecutor that Joe
Biden forced the ukrainians to fire
Victor Shogun coming out and saying Joe
Biden was being bribed by Ukraine
I have no doubt that there were illegal
activities engaged in by uh barisma as a
matter of fact the criminal case had
been started before me it continued to
expand and as lechevsky who at the time
held the post to minister and was the
founder and CEO of purisma started
bringing in people who could provide
protection for him Hunter Biden was
among them and the corruption Network
expanded as a result so yes to answer
your question there's no doubt in my
mind that burisma was engaged in illegal
activities had I continued to oversee
the purisma investigation we would have
found the facts about the corrupt
activities that they were engaging in
that included both Hunter Biden and
David Archer and others I do not want to
deal in unproven facts but my personal
conviction is that yes this was through
the case they were being bribed the fact
that Joe Biden gave away one billion
dollars in U.S money in exchange for my
dismissal my firing isn't that alone a
case of corruption
obviously it is and the clip that he's
referring to there Victor shulkin is
when Joe Biden publicly semi-publicly
because it was in a private event of the
Council on Foreign Relations but there
was a little camera in the back and
that's how this clip has gone viral Joe
Biden bragged about
paying the ukrainians a billion dollars
to fire the guy who is investigating the
company that was bribing him and his son
at least his son and according to the
text messages and emails that we've seen
would seem to suggest some of that money
a lot of that money was going to Joe
I remember going over convincing our
team our brothers to convincing us that
we should be providing for loan
guarantees and I went over right I guess
the 12 13th time to Kiev and and I was
going supposed to announce that there
was another billion dollar loan
guarantee and I had gotten a commitment
from poroshenko and from uh yatsenyuk
that they would take action against the
state prosecutor and they didn't so they
said they had they were walking out to
Prescott and said no I said I'm not
gonna or we're not going to give you the
billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting the billion dollars I said
you're not getting a billion I'm going
to be leaving here and I think it was
what six hours I look I said I'm leaving
in six hours and the prosecutor is not
fired you're not getting the money well
son of a
got fired and they put in place someone
who was solid
someone who is solidly going to stop
looking into the company that was paying
my family a ton of money in bribes
what more proof do we need
we talk a lot about political corruption
because one we like to attack our
political opponents but two we just live
in a particularly corrupt time
and so we we take these accusations with
a grain of salt in the case of Joe Biden
there is no more proof that we could
possibly have
unless we saw a public venmo payment
from Ukraine to Joe Biden that said for
all of the corruption there is no more
proof that we could possibly have
we've got Hunter Biden talking about how
the big guy gets 10 we get Hunter Biden
texting his family saying that unlike
his father he's never going to make them
give give to him half his salary half of
their salary we've got the the financial
documents showing all of these payments
from foreign powers to the Shell company
set up by Hunter Biden and Devin Archer
we've got the letters connecting Joe
Biden to Devin Archer and obviously to
Hunter Biden we now know thanks to the
House Republicans that Joe Biden was
conducting business while vice president
under a pseudonym
but Robert Ware and Robert L
I forget to let Peters Robert L Peters
several pseudonyms that he was
conducting not just little pleasantry
kind of business but was setting up
phone calls with the president of
Ukraine just obvious rank corruption and
yet no one's going to touch this guy
meanwhile Donald Trump what as president
called the secretary of state of Georgia
to inquire about the obvious voter fraud
that had gone on and they throw him in
the can for that and they take a mug
shot first mug shot of a U.S president
in American history
it's we are so obviously
beyond the point of
Law and Order of a of a serious justice
system that look in a way I have a
grudging kind of admiration for the for
the game that Joe Biden is playing that
guy is just a hustler through and
through a total gangster okay he's he's
not even really trying to hide it all
that hard the people that drive me the
craziest right now though are the
squishes
the ones who are trying to deal with in
these issues as though they were serious
matters for abstract legal reasoning
well you know listen I'm opposed to
arresting the leader of the opposition
I'm not saying it's a good thing that
we're arresting former presidents but
did Donald Trump
on when he was on the phone did he call
between three o'clock and four o'clock
or did he call between five o'clock and
six o'clock did what was the exact
nature of the statement that give me a
break man they would throw this guy in
prison for jaywalking they would throw
this guy in prison for not jaywalking
they he could he could walk across the
crosswalk
with the walk light on and they would
they would change the video footage and
say that it was a stop sign okay we are
so meanwhile Joe Biden is is sending his
son around to shake down every foreign
leader on planet Earth and say my dad's
going to give you American influence and
everybody looks the other way and they
get crooked plea deals and they get
diversion programs and they get nothing
Nary even a slap on the wrist
I'm I'm not saying this to point out the
hypocrisy normal people people with two
brain cells to rub together see the
hypocrisy I'm
I'm really mentioning this just to shake
the squishes out of their stupor we are
not living in a time of ordinary Law and
Order and people should recognize that
when it comes to the persecutions of
conservatives up to and including Donald
Trump but including hundreds and
hundreds at least more conservatives
than that so speaking of the mud shock
uh Trump raises seven million dollars
since this mug shot comes out
within the first 24 hours the campaign
raised 4.18 million dollars
which is similar to the amount of money
he raised after his first indictment
and since that time
he's raised 7.1 million dollars
this is why the election is very likely
just about Trump okay from the beginning
I think some people have accused me of
being too soft on Trump or too harsh in
the other candidates I don't think I've
done that not one day goes by where I
don't praise Ron DeSantis in some way or
Vivek ramaswamy in some way or even some
of the other candidates are polling in
the single digits but it has been my
contention from day one that regardless
of any of the virtues of the other
candidates
history and politics have come together
to make this election very likely about
Donald Trump
whether you got the best candidate in
Rhonda santis or Vivek ramaswamy or
Chris freaking Christie whatever it just
the type of election this is where
you've got practically an incumbent
running for a non-consecutive second
term for the first time in 140 years we
just we haven't seen that before it's
the same or we haven't seen that in
obviously over over 130 years now to say
nothing of the fact that Trump is a
celebrity for 40 years to say nothing
for the fact that the libs seem to
particularly hate this guy and they seem
to be willing to upend our entire legal
system to stop him not to stop Chris
Christie not to stop Mike Pence not to
stop Ron DeSantis maybe if any of those
guys were given a term maybe there's a
chance the libs would be willing to
upend our political order to stop them
but that is just not what's going on
right now which is why
it seems to me very likely that no
matter how good a campaign any of these
guys run Trump is going to maintain his
massive lead and Trump has basically
said as much
after the mug shot which we'll get to in
one second his his big statement after
the mug shot first though talk about
talk about having some gas in the tank
you know for these campaigns
do you have gas in your propane tank
well you're going to want to check out
cinch right now go to cinch.com use code
Knolls picture the perfect Summer Night
a warm breeze on your face as you Lounge
in your favorite chair outside the grill
is sizzling with Juicy Burgers in the
aroma of the food is irresistible boy
could you imagine now
imagine what this perfect summer night
would look like if you went to turn on
the grill and your propane tank were
empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door on your
schedule and they require no long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you do not
have to wait around at home track the
order on the Cinch app from anywhere
whether you're grilling steaks or
lighting up the patio heaters on a cold
night cinch's propane delivery service
ensures that you have the fuel you need
to make the most of every moment go
online to cinch.com or download the
Cinch app to order new customers can get
their first tank exchange for just 10
bucks with promo code Knolls go to
cinch.com or download the Cinch app use
promo code nulls kwles to get your first
tank exchange for just ten dollars
there's a limited time offer you must
live with an essential service area to
redeem it visit cinch.com offer for
details are you sick of what
corporations dragging your values
through the mud well
wash your hands of it with Jeremy's
brand new hand soap Jeremy's hand soap
is the perfect solution for everyday
grit and grime not to mention it smells
amazing and is scented with green tea
and citrus Jeremy actually cares about
you so he didn't put any of that paraben
crap in his hand soap not only is it
paraben free what's a paraben I don't
even know it's also free of sulfates Dei
ndsg plus it's not tested on animals and
it's made right here in the USA what
more could you want from your hand soap
than to get clean hands while keeping a
clean conscience so do yourself a favor
wash your hands of hypocritical Libs
once and for all
Jeremy's hand soap is the ideal addition
to your bathroom or kitchen sink as you
liberate your home from the influence of
woke companies go to Jeremy's racers.com
order your green tea and citrus hand
soap today
after the arrest setting the stage to
raise seven million bucks
this is the fourth indictment here's
Trump's statement I really believe this
is a very sad day for America this
should never happen if you challenge an
election you should be able to challenge
an election I thought the election was a
rigged election a stolen election
and I should have every right to do that
as you know you have many people that
you've been watching over the years do
the same thing whether it's Hillary
Clinton or Stacy Abrams or many others
when you uh have that great freedom to
challenge you have to be able to
otherwise you could have very dishonest
elections what has taken place here is
that travesty of Justice we did nothing
wrong I did nothing wrong and everybody
knows it I've never had such support and
that goes with the other ones too what
they're doing is election interference
they're trying to interfere with an
election there's never been anything
like it in our country before this is
their way of campaigning this is one
instance but you have three other
instances it's election interference so
I want to thank you for being here we
did nothing wrong at all and we have
every right every single right to
challenge an election that we think is
dishonest that we think it's very
dishonest
this is another part of my calculation
as to why I think it's very likely that
that guy is going to be the nominee
he is unflappable
maybe you hate Trump maybe you think
he's a big jerk maybe you think that
he's just not the best candidate in
2024. put that aside for a second
say that you were indicted
four times
federal charges State charges let's say
that you faced something like 750 years
in prison which even with the trumps
that tend to be a little long-lived
that's that's death in prison
you're facing all of this this is all a
very real possibility you've got the
entire weight of the American and
frankly Global liberal establishment
coming down on you and you will you
saunter out of the jail and you give a
statement like that
I don't know what it is I don't know
what it is that Trump has or what he's
missing that allows him to do that but
it is a reminder that
external circumstances are not going to
change this guy they're not going to get
him off message you might hate his
message but they're not going to get him
off message they're not going to change
his personality he's got he would have
given that that same statement on a
sunny day in July seven years ago
and it's not going to change the facts
of the election you might say we
shouldn't focus on 2020 you might say we
need to look forward not backward you
maybe all of that's true
but the fact is the Liberals rigged the
last election even if you think that the
way they rigged it wouldn't have changed
the final outcome that Joe Biden would
have won anyway it is simply a fact they
changed the way the elections were
conducted
to such a degree that you had tens of
millions more votes to such a degree
that you had widespread mail-in ballots
in contravention of the state
constitution in the case of Pennsylvania
took a week or more to count the ballots
completely absurd and so the election
will be about election Integrity in a
way it's an election about elections
it's a metapolitical moment and you
might say oh this is terrible it's going
to hurt Republicans chances maybe it
will
I'm not saying that it won't I'm just
saying that is the state of play right
now and if they could at least off foot
the guy if they could if they could make
him cry a little if they could make him
stumble if they could make him change
his message then maybe you say okay it's
a lively contest but if nothing is
changing
and the guy's 40 points up in the polls
how is any other candidate going to
knock him down not saying it can't
happen I'm just saying it seems very
unlikely so are the other candidates
viable there's some good news for
supporters of the other candidates
coming out this week which is
538 the the liberal
election polling Outlet says that Ron
DeSantis won the GOP Presidential debate
they say that he's slightly edged out
Vivek ramaswamy New York Post says the
opposite says Vivek won the debate and
that he slightly edged out Ron DeSantis
but both of those Outlets agree that
DeSantis and Vivek were the two clear
winners of the debate that Trump did not
show up to now 538 goes further
this is other good news at least
apparently for the DeSantis campaign
they say that more voters are now
considering voting for DeSantis than for
any other candidate including Trump
now you might hear that statement and
say well hold on that doesn't make any
sense because Donald Trump is still 40
points up in the polls how is how is
DeSantis beating Trump in terms of
openness to vote for him well because
the question is different it's not who
are you going to vote for it's not who
is your favorite candidates who would
you be willing to vote for so more
people are open to the idea of voting
for DeSantis than of any other candidate
including Trump meaning there are there
are going to be some people who really
like Nikki Haley but they're open to
voting for DeSantis there's some people
who really like Vivek maybe they're open
to DeSantis there's some people who
really like Trump they're open to
DeSantis whereas
for Trump
there are there are more people who are
just saying nah I will not under any
circumstances vote for that guy so
that's nice that people are open to
DeSantis but as I've said from the
beginning the kind of campaign that
DeSantis is running in these
circumstances is a great campaign to get
you to number two it's a great campaign
to get you to the first loser but he is
not running the kind of campaign that
can at the at the present moment can
overtake the front runner
you would have to run a much Bolder
campaign to do that and even then the
historical circumstances might be such
that it's not possible even if people
are open to voting for you doesn't help
those poll numbers according to realtor
politics now
and this is
largely not all of the polls in the
average here but but most of them are
factoring in the debate
uh
Trump is at 53 DeSantis is at 13. the
vague is at seven and a half Haley's at
five and Pence at 4.7 and Christy at 2.8
and just down on from there
Doug burgum still holding on at 0.6
percent
so it doesn't seem to to have moved that
all that much and then moving away from
the polls for a second maybe you say the
polls don't tell you anything look at
the betting odds so this is where people
are actually putting their money down on
who they think the likely nominee is
right now the the top three people are
Trump the vague and DeSantis
and importantly here
for Trump of Aiken DeSantis Trump's
numbers are increasing desantises and
viveks are slightly decreasing in
January it's worth pointing out in the
betting markets DeSantis was way up over
Trump the the the money people thought
that it was much more likely that
DeSantis would be the nominee than the
Trump would be the nominee it has
steadily reversed ever since then Mike
so my question to the campaigns is what
could change you could say maybe a
consolidation of the candidates
if all the other candidates got out then
maybe the the fact that a lot of people
are open to voting for DeSantis maybe
that would help him to get the edge over
Trump but even then I bet a lot of the
people who were open to DeSantis are
still people who who would take Trump as
number one so question what could change
now
we talk about how the Republican party
is so divided oddly enough it's not that
divided right now
the people who don't like the front
runner might say well it's very divided
and I don't feel that I have a home in
the Republican party but
the party has coalesced largely around a
candidate
and it's the one that everybody has a
strong opinion on whether they love him
or hate him speaking of division
Switching gears somewhat this is a store
I wanted to get to last week I do want
to get to it now
Halle Berry
has gotten divorced
I don't really care about the personal
lives of celebrities I guess marriage
and divorce are public matters so it's
not that's not just your private life
marriage is a public thing but what
makes the story kind of interesting is
that this divorce has been going on for
something like eight years
Halle Berry has agreed to her child
support payments to her ex-husband they
finalize their divorce eight years after
this custody battle began
started in 2015 and here's what Halle
Berry said in 2015. it is with a heavy
heart that we have come to the decision
to divorce we move forward with love and
respect for one another and the shared
focus of what is best for our son
that is a nonsensical statement
we are we are deciding to divorce now
because we are totally focused on what
is best for our child
that's not possible
it's not possible
maybe in the most extreme rare
circumstance where you've got you know
an abusive husband or something like
that threatening the the wife and the
children I see the argument for a kind
of a separation there that's that's not
what's going on here that's not what's
going on in the vast majority of cases
of divorce what what people say in most
cases of divorce as well
well look it's it's not no it's not
about any threats to the children or to
me it's just it's that I just we need to
be happier you know that's exactly what
Halle Berry said she said I just feel
fulfilled I feel happy in my life
romantically as a mother as an artist
I'm a much better mother in this
circumstance than I would have been had
I stayed in the Romantic relationship
that didn't serve me and didn't make me
feel the way I need to feel as a woman
I'm reminded that we always have to take
care of ourselves first because I can't
be a good mother for my children if I'm
not fundamentally happy and feeling good
about myself this
woman is completely wrong
it is amazing to have a statement with
this many sentences where every single
one of them is just completely and
totally wrong
me me that's all that matters I'm a much
better mother in the circumstance where
you're not putting your children first
no that makes you a worse mother I'm not
knocking you entirely I know it's a
tough world I know people do get
divorced I know we deal with all the
problems of evil pervading this this
Fallen place that that that there are
but it's not better
to say it's better that's just a lie I'm
remind we need to take care of ourselves
first no when you're a when you're a
parent your responsibility is to take
care of your children first you have to
think about other people sometimes more
than yourself I know that's in our
modern culture it's very difficult to
think about and in Hollywood it's
virtually impossible to think about
I can't be a good mother for my children
if I'm not fundamentally happy yes you
can you know how you can by just doing
the stuff you're supposed to do and
shutting up about your feelings that's
that's how you can that's how we can all
do it I'm not just knocking Halle Berry
here this is true for everybody
you can be a good husband and a good
wife and a good father and a good mother
and a good employee and a good member of
your community
even if you're not totally perky all day
long you know how you do it you shut up
about your feelings and you think about
anybody for even one second other than
yourself and if we all did that just
like five percent more than we do our
nation our local communities all the way
up to our national Community would be so
much better we would solve so many of
our problems
just that easily
my favorite comment on Friday comes from
polygon crazy
who says surprised they haven't started
arresting people that showed up to
support president Trump I'm expecting to
see that any day now you don't need to
wait to to see it that's been happening
now for years
that's what the January 6th people are
about
the January 6th people
overwhelmingly were nice Midwestern
people
I guess from all parts of the country
who showed up walked around the capitol
rotunda and got thrown in solitary
confinement for it Midwestern grannies
eccentrics who show up in crack of
course on the capitol grounds and then
they they wind up in the clink
and you might say well well just like
those these wonk people these squishy
liberal people who say well you know
um let's just let's analyze the charges
against Donald Trump this isn't just a
complete joke show trial Banana Republic
persecution no let's let's examine well
what exactly did you say in the phone
call give me a break
give me a break BLM gets to burn the
country down for eight months and then
some Midwestern Granny gets thrown in
the Clank for showing up to the nation's
capital in the house that's supposed to
be the representation for the people
it's a joke but even beyond the January
6th people
sorry strong number six people the thing
about Douglas Mackey Douglas Mackey is
this guy who had a social media account
Ricky Vaughn on Twitter it didn't even
have that many followers it had like 58
000 followers and he sent out memes
memes about the election little memes
and jokes that we all that everybody's
joked about forever you know well if
you're a Republican vote Tuesday if
you're a Democrat vote Wednesday that
kind of a thing and then just really
spicy edgy memes that that were meant to
provoke people to say he's racist sexist
phobic this is status okay you might you
might not like his memes or something
you might not have followed him on
Twitter the guy's facing 10 years in
prison for memes because he opposed the
ruling class and because he supported
Donald Trump so you don't need to wait
for them to round up ordinary Trump
supporters it's happening already and
they're facing years and years
in prison
now
speaking of places where people live
be it prison or the homes that are
increasingly broken in our country
new homes are shrinking in size I teased
this story on Friday
this is my little tease it's not the
sexiest story
it's not the most scintillating
sensationalist tabloid story but it
tells you something really deep about
our country
yeah this is from Wall Street Journal
goodbye bathtub and living room
America's homes are shrinking faced with
high mortgage rates constrained
Americans are embracing smaller homes
for many Americans homeownership may be
attainable only if they give up the
dining room home prices are in your
record highs frustrating millions of
potential buyers to say nothing of the
fact that interest rates are not through
the roof
since 2018 the average unit size for new
housing starts has decreased 10 percent
nationally to 2420 square feet now I I
read that number and I thought man
that's a mansion 2400 Square the house I
grew up in I grew up in an apartment for
a lot of my upbringing but then we I
grew up in a house that was I think 800
square feet I thought 2400 is pretty
good except you gotta you gotta remember
I grew up in New York
if you grow up in the middle of the
country where real estate is cheaper
okay 2400 that's not as big as it used
to be and then in other places you look
at Seattle
newly built homes
are 18 smaller than they were five years
ago Charlotte North Carolina and San
Antonio 14 smaller than they were four
years ago
this stuff is shrinking really really
fast
why
in part it's shrinkflation it's the
reason that when you go to the grocery
store you get less coffee in the tin of
coffee than you did
a few years ago
you get fewer Donuts in the bag of
donuts it's because when inflation is
rampant as it has been under Joe Biden
uh
companies know that they can't just Jack
the price up 50 or you'll be so shocked
by that so they'll Jack the price up 20
but then they'll shrink the package so
the cost per unit goes up a lot that's
part of the reason but but it's also
because
our families are shrinking
people have many fewer children now than
they did 50 years ago
it's also because our whole population
is shrinking we have a dining population
in the United States as we have for 50
years
and that trend has accelerated at
various times in those 50 years
our whole our whole civilization is
shrinking it's smaller than it used to
be
our view of art you walk into a
cathedral in Europe or even in America
you walk into Saint Pat's cathedral in
New York this is big this is Grand this
is huge this is beautiful you look at
modern architecture it's small
you look at more traditional
architecture it's ornamented there's a
lot to it there are a lot of details to
take in modern architecture you look at
the new homes that people are building
you know those hideous like black and
white kind sometimes Cube
now occasionally more angular
monstrosities they look like prisons
they look like the kind of place you get
sent if you send memes out on Twitter
supporting Donald Trump you know they
they don't they're just small and ugly
you see this in the the novel The
Fountainhead by Ein Rand her slightly
lesser red novel to Atlas Shrugged and
slightly smaller but equally bad The
Fountainhead is a novel about Iran's
philosophy of objectivism which is an
atheist materialist ideology but it's
it's also about architecture and what's
so funny about the book is Ein Rand is
wrong about 97 of things she she
actually gets to some interesting truths
about human nature about three percent
of the time but it's just totally
covered up in a bunch of muck and false
anthropology and and theology
but she the most striking thing about
the novel which is about architecture is
that she's wrong about architecture
the protagonist of the novel makes uh a
church he's supposed to make a cathedral
basically and it's this small tiny ugly
crappy modern place
the the the vision that the protagonist
of the story pursues so doggedly without
getting any advice from anybody
including the people who are paying for
his plans his artistic vision is ugly
it's just modernist
unhuman small
stuff it's ugly and so it's no surprise
that everything's shrinking you know we
joke about how the libs want to make us
all eat bugs and live in pods this is
how they do it the way they make you
live in a pod is not by putting a gun to
your head
and saying get in the Pod now surf you
know the way they make you live in a pod
is they shrink your expectations they
shrink your vision of the world
of course they they make it they shrink
your hopes and your your dreams and your
imagination
such that you are content living in a
way that is not fitting of a dignified
human being speaking of reduction
is another headline where the libs
inadvertently tell us how they view
Humanity
here's the headline put pest animal
species on the pill don't call them says
scientist
Humane alternatives to killing rampant
creatures such as wild boar deer and
gray squirrels are being developed so
you know these wild boar are huge pests
in a lot of the country especially in
like Texas so sometimes people they'll
just go out and say hey man hunt as many
of these damn things as you want we just
want to kill them there will be people
who will go up in helicopters and just
shoot these things from the sky okay so
what this scientist says is no no
don't go out there and kill them that's
kind of nasty and feels unethical what
you should do is just sterilize them
and then I thought Okay so
the these Masters of the Universe who
want to control the population that they
consider to be pests the way that they
do that the way that they think is the
cleverest without arousing the ire of
environmentalists and humanitarians and
all the like by outright slaughtering
them is they're just going to put them
on contraceptive drugs
but wait a second
aren't they doing that to us
hold on is it aren't we human beings in
our society constantly inundated with
contraceptive propaganda from the moment
that we're in elementary school now all
the way up through our 20s and 30s
everywhere bombarded by the public
health departments bombarded by the
public school system bombarded by
Hollywood now invited by every
influential institution the scientific
establishment all of it to say hey get
on the pill
sterilize yourself don't have children
it's bad to have children
I put those two together and I said well
how does our liberal Elite think about
us
if they're doing to us the same thing
that they're advocating doing to pest
animal species
guess it means they think of us as pests
and of course they do sometimes they'll
tell us that so there's too many people
we're the problem
you know we've got it we just have
overpopulation we gotta they'll say it
openly and not just Fringe people you'll
hear Bill Gates talk about this you'll
you'll hear billionaires
you'll hear the talking head shattering
class pundit stat your politicians talk
about about this kind of a thing
now I've got a good story and a bad
story
and there I'm gonna have to
I can't believe I'm gonna have to tease
again I've been such a tease on the show
but it's music Monday so we've got to
get to a new Miley Cyrus song before
that though here's my little tease
Santana The Rocker made a big splash
last week because he came out and he
said
I don't know you have to bleep me on
YouTube He said
a woman is a woman and a man is a man
and then
Santana
before I could even talk about this on
the show
he apologized
but he everyone's focused on the woman
is a woman and a man as a man then
everybody started to focus on the
apology and they're missing there's one
aspect of Santana's rant about in the
sexual Revolution that is so insightful
and beautiful and and the leftists are
going to hate it if they acknowledge it
and even many conservatives have
forgotten this lesson and it's a lesson
that we're gonna have to get to tomorrow
how's that for a tease because today's
music Monday and we've got a new Miley
Cyrus song and you know that while I
listen to basically no new modern music
I
kind of like Miley Cyrus I have a soft
spot for her okay I do whatever ever
since Party in the USA I've had a soft
spot for my life the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code knowlescana
wlas a check out for two months free on
all annual plans
yeah
foreign
[Music]